[Music]
on this Thursday night mounting anxiety
about Beijing giving Moscow a boost the
conversation Ukraine's president wants
with his Chinese counterpart Russian
China are moving closer and closer
together NATO's warning to China and
Ukraine's year of constant grieving
people have been crying for a year the
fatigue from funerals and the fighting
troubling Trend the record number of
incidents involving Canadian police
using deadly force and Google's Power
Play We depend upon creepy flow of
information on the internet why the tech
giant is blocking certain news sites
from its search results
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with developments in Russia's war
on Ukraine the head of NATO says he has
seen signs China may be planning to
supply Russia with weapons China's
leadership is expected to set out its
position on how to settle the Ukraine
conflict through political means
tomorrow the anniversary of the
full-scale invasion at the U.N today a
resolution calling for a peace agreement
that guarantees Ukraine's sovereignty
was adopted though the world is far from
United several countries abstained
including China Iran India South Africa
and Pakistan Jackson prosco has our top
story tonight
Spain's prime minister is the latest
leader to travel to Kiev
marking a week of visits where Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski praised
Western allies and warned of a potential
new threat from the East we would like
to meet with China zielinski said it is
important that all countries be on our
side on the side of Justice
exactly where China stands will come
into view Friday Chinese president Xi
Jinping will reveal his own peace plan
signaling how far China is willing to go
to support Russia's war in terms of a
security Alliance I think Russia and
China are moving closer and closer
together
this week China's top Diplomat sat down
with Vladimir Putin to reaffirm their No
Limits partnership Ukraine and NATO
worry China will do more than just talk
and could provide weapons to Russia we
have seen signs that they are
considering and may be planning for that
in increasingly blunt terms NATO's
Secretary General warned China to stay
out of the conflict China should of
course not support Russia's illegal War
Russia's War aggression against
Ukraine is a violation of the U.N
Charter
at the U.N Ukraine's foreign minister
oppressed Nations to pass a motion
demanding a halt to The Invasion it
passed overwhelmingly
none of it changes the course of this
year-long conflict
one in which Ukraine and Russia
desperately need allies to keep up the
fight
Jackson prosco Global News Washington
a little later we'll look at a key
battle over a prized airport that was
one of the first strategic losses for
Russia in this country five more
provinces have signed on to the new
health care deal proposed by the federal
government though they have yet to come
up with specific plans for how they'll
spend the money and prove their Health
Care Systems are getting better
Catherine Ward explains
since the beginning of the month the
federal government has been talking
Health coast to coast to coast making
good on their promise to get bilateral
agreements in place when we made the
health care announcement and we had the
meeting for meeting with the first
ministers a few weeks ago I said we were
going to get moving forward on
negotiations within weeks not months and
that's exactly what we're doing the
Prime Minister announced Ontario Nova
Scotia Pei New Brunswick and
Newfoundland and Labrador have all
agreed in principle to the government's
health care plan the goal being to get
those agreements in place that are
specific for each province and territory
and cater to their individual needs
we're looking for ambitious targets that
are reasonable for them that they can
hit that they can be accountable to that
will improve access to Primary Care in a
significant way earlier this month the
government of Canada offered premiers 46
billion in new money for Health Care
over the next decade in addition each
province will also receive a one-time
Canada Health transfer Top-Up rate
ranging from 9 million to over 700
million dollars on a per Province basis
however the Prime Minister reinforced
the notion that certain metrics must be
met to get the funding a key Focus being
data collection to ensure continuity of
care for patients across the country for
data we need to make sure that people
are developing sophisticated Data
Systems that allow them to empower
their Health Community to have the
proper information on all the patients
they're treating and be comparable and
give us a national picture of how health
is doing in Canada with clear outcomes
and numbers Catherine Ward Global News
Toronto
Canada's Federal privacy Watchdog has
launched a joint investigation with
three provinces into the social media
giant Tick Tock the Privacy Commissioner
of Canada along with authorities in BC
Alberta and Quebec will look into the
collection use and disclosure of
personal information by Tick Tock which
is owned by a Chinese parent company
called bite dance critics warn the
Chinese government could access user
data such as browsing history and
location the probe will have a
particular focus on how tick tock's
privacy practices affect younger people
using the app well if you tried to
Google a news story today you may
already know this the world's most
popular search engine has begun blocking
some Canadians from seeing content from
certain news sites Google calls it a
test run of its response to the federal
government's online news bill which
would compel companies like Facebook and
Google to compensate news organizations
for republishing their content David
Aiken explains what's behind the spat
between a billion dollar tech company
and the government
what did you expect the tech companies
to do when faced with that proposition
Michael Geist is a law professor who
specializes in technology issues he has
been a sharp critic of the Trudeau
government's online news act bill c-18
he's testified that it could set a bad
precedent and inhibit free speech that
it mandates payments for links which I
think has a real creates real concerns
for freedom of expression online we
depend upon free flow of information on
the internet links is Central to that
the bill would force the world's biggest
media and tech companies like Google and
Facebook owner meta to pay Canadian news
organizations for every link back to a
news site the Parliamentary budget
officer estimates that could transfer
nearly 330 million dollars a year from
the tech companies to Canadian news
organizations and about three quarters
of that will in fact go to broadcasters
so uh the broadcasters tend to be uh
Bell Rogers uh and CBC and of course
chorus with global most of those
companies are pretty large companies
with an awful lot of money so people are
already said some people are saying well
do they need to be subsidized Google
doesn't think so and so as a warning it
says it is engaging in a five-week long
test in which four percent of its
Canadian users will see access to
Canadian news sites limited although it
did not provide details about how those
users are chosen or which new sites are
affected the government says it will not
be dissuaded we just want Facebook and
Google to pay their fair share to
journalists when they use their work and
I think that's a reasonable thing to ask
and they've been fighting against
regulation
um we think we're on the right side of
this for Google this is not just about
its Canadian operations it is worried
about copycat legislation in other
countries and that would affect Google's
Global bottom line David Aiken Global
News
Ottawa
there is evidence Police use of deadly
force in this country is on the rise
according to information gathered by
academics and advocacy groups it found
in 2022 police officers killed 69 people
the highest number in a single year and
there are persistent racial disparities
black and Indigenous people account for
more than 27 percent of police involved
shooting deaths the group says no
government body in Canada tracks police
killings and as Heather urich's West
reports that data is crucial if anything
is going to change
on Christmas Day at this gas station in
Strathmore Alberta a sick sick of First
Nation Man became one of 69 people
killed last year by police which
according to our data is the highest on
record that we've seen criminologist
Alexandra McClelland is the principal
investigator of a new data and
transparency project that is working to
bring the number of police involved
deaths to light going back to the year
2000 the project found there have been
704 police involved deaths where there
was use of force with most of those
deaths occurring within the last 10
years in fact researchers found a 66.5
percent increase in the number of deaths
recorded between 2011 and 2022 compared
to the previous 10-year period we
decided to develop this database make it
transparent to the Canadian public so
that people can hold to account ask
questions there can be scrutiny
accountability after
after a Minneapolis Police Officer
murdered George Floyd an unarmed black
man in the summer of 2020. the issue
became an emotional flash point the use
of force of police was scrutinized like
never before three years later the new
Canadian data set shows things are
becoming much worse indigenous people
black people people of color are amongst
those that are most impacted by by
police involved deaths the data set
doesn't track the Cirque
leading to each officer involved death
and the Ontario Provincial Police
Association believes more research is
required to explain why these numbers
are on the rise it's hard to say if
we're policing in a more dangerous time
but um you know five police officers
have been killed in the line of duty in
in Canada in in the last six months or
so
uh that's very concerning to the law
enforcement Community another set of
disturbing numbers that highlight a
serious problem facing Canadian
communities and the Need For impactful
Change Heather York's West Global News
Calgary
crippling cold weather in parts of
Canada and the U.S coming up the
nightmare for travelers on the ground
and in the air
Southern Ontario is digging out from a
winter Wallop today
[Music]
a messy mix of snow and ice blanketed
the greater Toronto area after a storm
moved through overnight more than 100
flights at Pearson Airport were canceled
after the storm dumped about 17
centimeters of snow tens of thousands of
people in Southwestern Ontario lost
power and some may not have it back
until tomorrow night
it was bitterly cold across the Prairies
today as well in Calgary the
temperatures expected to dip to -31
tonight down to minus 40 with the wind
chill and look at the environment Canada
alerts for Alberta and Saskatchewan both
provinces are entirely under extreme
cold warnings a chinook is expected to
bring Calgary out of the Deep Freeze
there by Saturday
and extreme weather across the northern
U.S has led to power outages flight
cancellations and road closures more
than 24 million people in two dozen
states are now under winter weather
advisories highways are a mess this
police officer in Wyoming barely escaped
the path of a runaway semi that barreled
off the road air Travelers also faced a
second day of disruptions over 900
flights were canceled
scenes of War ahead we hear from a
Ukrainian Soldier involved in a
strategic battle at an airport near
Keith
as we approach the anniversary of the
war in Ukraine we want to take you back
to a defining moment at the start of
Russia's full-scale Invasion Elite
Russian troops descended on hostemel
Airport an ideal spot to land large
personnel carriers it's about 30
kilometers from the center of Kiev
Crystal gemancing was granted sweeping
access to that airport during her
coverage of the war and she has more on
that pivotal battle
in a suburb of Kiev the chuff of
helicopter rotors were some of the first
sounds of War
definitely Russian says the man
capturing the images
they're headed towards the airport
hostel Mill airport was under attack
besieged by Elite Russian forces
the airport was home to Aerospace giant
Antonov and had close proximity to Kiev
making it a strategic prize for invading
forces seeking to capture the capital
and overthrow the government
of company spokesperson says the attack
began just before noon a rocket landed
near the administration building where
roughly 50 employees were working
outside paratroopers were landing and
sweeping across the field
thing so those staircase that staircase
is that chicken yes
Global News was granted access to the
ruined airport in August Twisted Metal
destroyed military vehicles and damaged
planes littered the grounds looming over
the ruined site the remnants of the
world's largest cargo plane the Maria a
symbol of Ukrainian Pride the plane once
used to Ferry Russian space shuttles was
the last of its kind
satellite images picked up the onslaught
that raged below Global News spoke with
one soldier with the call sign Zeus who
was involved in that battle were only
using his first name Demetrio and not
disclosing his location
I think they were aware of our presence
because we fought them back during those
first days Demetrio and others were
deployed to the airport late on the 24th
after the National Guard unit stationed
there was overwhelmed and was forced to
abandon their post he recalls the cold
surviving for 14 days outside without a
sleeping bag or warm clothes and how
they covertly moved around spying on the
Russians and Reporting back their
positions
the artillery was working quite
precisely I think they understood that
someone was passing on information about
their targets the matrio says accurate
and continuous pressure thwarted
Russia's plans to turn the airport into
a Russian base for ammunition food and a
drop location for troops it was quite
obvious that the Russians will try to
take the customer because it was the
closest airport to the capital which
direction they will come what troops
will be I think nobody knew it military
expert and former polish Captain mache
milchanowski says Russia's best soldiers
LED that attack he says what we know so
far about the Battle of hostemail reads
like a drama
I think it will be a lot of movies about
that in in the next years the full story
might be lost in the fog of War we don't
know exactly how many soldiers fought
here or how many were killed it's even
contested which side destroyed the Maria
the company Commander for the National
Guard unit Vitali radenco says all of
his men survive though some were
captured
it was a strategic point he says it all
started here that first battle took
place here
just outside of the gates to the airport
are residential buildings Tatiana
ostapochuk told Global News the
community was occupied by Russian forces
for 38 days residents many still afraid
did not want to appear on camera some
were taken captive all were terrorized
that fateful battle here one of the
first strategic losses for Russia now
seen as a pivotal event that helped turn
the course of the war Crystal commencing
Global News London
a nation grieving next the toll after a
year at War
[Music]
we often talk about the strength and the
resilience of the Ukrainian people this
past year has been a dismal endurance
test what we don't report on that often
are the individual lives lost Jeff
sample spent time in leviv and brings us
the story behind one of the many
soldiers who made the ultimate sacrifice
and the grief of the loved ones left
behind
before last year's Russian invasion
Alicia skalska and her husband Roman
used to go for walks in this park beside
the cemetery now she's burying him here
next to so many others because the
cemetery is full
they were married in June just a small
ceremony she says they plan to have a
larger one after the war Roman had
started his own business but after
Russia invaded he became a soldier sent
to the front lines on the other side of
the country before Christmas he was
asked by a local reporter to record a
holiday message
dear ukrainians Happy New Year and merry
Christmas he said we the Armed Forces of
Ukraine will try to give you the best
gift thank you for your support happy
holidays a few weeks later the 26 year
old was killed by a Russian mortar
he was so responsible he loved playing
with his nephews says his mother now
left to bury her son Licia is now a 24
year old Widow
we had so many beautiful memories
together she says
I have lost a lot of friends this year
her husband was one of three soldiers
buried on this day over the past year at
this Garrison Church in Western Ukraine
funerals have become an almost daily
heart-wrenching ritual
the church holds funerals very often the
priest says we are tired from funerals
Global News first visited this church
last March during the early days of
Russia's full-scale invasion
seeing firsthand the intense grief
at funerals for some of the first
soldiers killed
one year later their morning feels more
subdued
people have been crying for a year he
says people are exhausted and yet they
push forward
shuffling past rows of generators that
now power cities like leviv the
electricity grid under constant Russian
attack the threat of long-range missile
and drone strikes now routine it's
almost a year of this now how are you
how are you feeling
we're so tired after all this
an I.T professional before The Invasion
and served with Roman in Donetsk day by
day
um
the part of your life
currently unfortunately
it is like a normal lifestyle for you
and it is disgusting the cemetery and
the church are filled with the faces of
those lost along with photos of their
children left behind
but even as the number of dead grows so
too does their resolve
we can't bring Roman back but we can win
she says please say in your report that
we need more help more weapons
people are tired but the main thing they
want is Victory the priest says it's
their life it's their country so they
understand it's not possible to rest at
the moment
to ensure their loved ones did not die
in vain Jeff Semple Global News leviv
and we will have a special report on
Saturday at 7 30 to mark one year since
the full-scale Russian invasion of
Ukraine instead of our usual your Canada
photo tonight we leave you with an image
from Paris the Eiffel Tower has been lit
up in the colors of Ukraine's flag a
sign of solidarity on the eve of the
anniversary of Russia's Invasion that is
global national for this Thursday thanks
for watching bye-bye
[Music]
foreign